all right um welcome everyone to the
ddps seminar before we introduce our
invited speaker let's go over some rules
and Logistics first of all please mute
yourself during the talk but if you have
questions you can unmute and ask
questions or use chat room to post your
questions so that we can address them in
Q&A session at the end second today's
ddps seminar is open to external
audiences uh therefore no classified
discussion is allowed so please watch
out finally The Talk today will be
recorded and uploaded in our YouTube
channel okay that's about it now let me
briefly introduce our speaker today it
is an honor to host Dr borkul Bal who is
an assistant professor in the department
of chemical biomolecular engineering and
they resident faculty in the center for
clean energy engineering at un
University of Conneticut she holds a
bachelor's degree in chemical and
biological engineering from Koch
University in master degree in chemical
engineering from carneg melon University
and PhD degree in chemical engineering
from Texas A&M University before joining
uh University of Connecticut buru was a
post-doctoral research research
associate at the Texas A&M energy
Institute our research focuses on data
Centric uh process systems engineering
and machine learning of energy critical
systems spending chemical environmental
and bio biological domains among her
ours uh are the American Chemical
Society petroleum research fund doctoral
new investigator award uh the two 2020
cast directors award and outstanding
graduate student award from Texas A&M
she was also selected as an rising star
in chemical engineering by the message
chest um the MIT in
2019 today uh she will talk about a data
driven process systems engineering
approach for Supply Chain management and
Enterprise wide uh optimization please
enjoy and expect a wonderful talk now
let me ask a one questions to baru just
to um get to know more better and to
make this seminar somewhat informal um
okay here's question you ready
yes all right um obviously you are
passionate about data driven um you know
method and numerical optimization what
aspects of the of them Fascinate and
excite
you um it really I think the endless
opportunities uh every single day I'm
discovering something new about them and
there and how we can use them in a more
clear way or on a more clever way um so
um I think you know um the power with
with data is is really really big and um
it really is going to shape our lives in
a in a more different way in the
upcoming decades I
guess yeah I think that's how everyone
feels these days right thank you so much
uh the stage is
yours thank you so much for the very
kind introduction and thank you so much
for the invitation as well uh it is it
is an honor to be here to present uh
what we have been working in the past
couple of years and also uh I was
mentioning uh this before everyone
joined but uh I did see a couple of
mentors uh that presented in the seminar
Series so that makes this presentation
uh a little extra special for me H and
and exciting for me today I'm going to
talk about data driven optimization
mainly and how we can use data driven
optimization to address address very
tailored and very difficult types of
problems uh and and the problems that we
see mainly in Supply Chain management
and enterprise-wide optimization type of
problems but before going into that uh I
am a chemical engineer by training so I
do want to uh start by sort of
motivating uh why process systems
engineering is is a bit important to to
address this problem so as chemical
Engineers we design and operate chemical
processes and these chemical processes
could be shown in in uh block diagrams
or process flow sheets and what the idea
essentially here is that you start from
a raw material you go through series of
uh processing
units and you're trying to uh get to
this final product and as you can see
there's this selected route but there
are many different routes in the
background that exist so the natural
question becomes is that that for
example which one is the most profitable
one which one is the most sustainable
one if I selected one route what are my
operating conditions for each of these
these unit operations what's my
temperature what's my pressure and
generally the question is is the process
safe so inherently uh this is a
decision-making problem and the reality
of that is you cannot Implement all
these Alternatives in real life so think
of you're trying to design a reactor uh
it's not really safe or or really sound
to create one Reactor with a with like
five lit reactor then go to 10 liters
then to 15 lers and play around with
temperature and pressure and see what
really sticks so what we do is we take
these um chemical design and operation
problems and represent them with
mathematical models and these
mathematical models are going to entail
our first principles of mass energy
momentum balances uh so we will be
following physics
we will we can have process constraints
that we don't want to violate so for
example temperature of a reactor
shouldn't may be exceeding um some some
value due to safety safety
considerations and we will always have
some degrees of freedom like our
decision variables could be operating
conditions uh design considerations and
many other things when these are
attached to goals now they become an
optimization problem and uh we can try
to minimize CO2 emissions we can have
different objectives for example for the
reactor example you may want to maximize
your yield you may want to maximize your
profit but more formally these
optimization problems are given in this
kinetical form uh so assuming that we
have bounded decision variables we can
have a very nonlinear non-convex
objective function we can have linear
constraints or nonlinear constraints and
what we do is we look at the
intersection of the Fe ible region
evaluate our objective function and we
can pinpoint where our optimal solution
is now this example is onedimensional
it's pictorial and we can plot
everything and pinpoint where uh the
optimal solution is at but more formally
uh what you do is you can do the active
set approach so for example uh we have
two decision variables in this uh in
this PO uh optimization problem we we
have quadratic objective with linear
constraints and what you do with the
active set approach is that you assume
no active constraints and you write your
lran which is which is going to be
essentially your objective
function then what you do is you
calculate the gradient of the lran and
you solve for X1 and X2 so you have two
equations two unknowns and you get uh
some values for your decision variables
then what you do is you go and check
your constraint violation
so in this case constraints 2 three and
four are satisfied but constraint one is
violated so what we need to do is go
back and uh take this constraint as
active so now our legrangian uh
considers the objective function and our
active constraint we take the gradient
make it equal to zero we have three
equations three unknowns so we have the
two decision variables and our larange
multiplier and then we check our
constraint violations our first
constraint is active so we satisfi that
the the second third and fourth are also
satisfied and our lrange multiplier is
greater than equal to zero so we say
that we found the solution now this is
obviously a very quick intro to
fundamentals of optimization but there's
only one information I would like you to
take from it and that is to find the
optimal solution you need the gradient
information and the problems that we are
actually working on today this gradient
information information or this
derivative information is not very easy
to come by so first of all we're using
increasingly complex simulation software
so we can capture the underlying physics
much much better uh due to the
increasing computation power but that
means that we're expressing our systems
with ordinal differential equations or
worth a set of partial differential
equations and when you're trying to do
this type of um active set approach it's
not very trivial to find the gradient of
a set of ODS you actually need to treat
them to be able to use deterministic
methods um so there's an challenge with
regards to the complexity of the models
we have second we're interested in
solving multiscale design problems um
these design problems can span over
multiple temporal and spatial scales so
you can start from atomistic Level
calculations and go up to the supply
chain analysis and because you need to
integrate these different temporal
spatial scales to your models again you
have a very complicated mathematical
system at the end that is not very easy
to solve and third uh we have explosion
of data we would like to gain insights
from data data is now uh very powerful
uh for decision- making but we want to
be able to use uh this information and
in all these three cases that you will
notice the derivatives of objectives or
the or the constraints that we
absolutely needed to be able to find the
optimal solution is going to be
partially available totally intractable
or the problem is going to be very hard
to solve using deterministic methods and
this third bullet point this hard to
solve uh is is quite important because
that really motivates us uh with our
enterprise-wide optimization or Supply
Chain management uh type of problems so
if we go back and look at our initial S
sort of pictorial uh optimization
formulation where we had our equations
explicitly available to us and we were
able to plot them and show where the
optimal solution is now we're looking at
a case where all or a subset of
equations are not going to be available
in close form so our system is now
represented with data and we're trying
to pinpoint the same optimal Solution by
looking at data and that brings me to um
to our current research directions
within with in my research group uh the
very core capability we have is is
essentially data driven optimization
algorithms that is something that I'm
going to really focus on today and give
you an application of that on Supply
Chain management but we're also
interested in using these techniques for
uh process control uh so uh micrology
cultivation is something that can uh
benefit from this we also do more bread
and butter type of process design um
studies with especially sea water Dell
nation and again we have a really core
program on uh more bread and butter data
analytics machine learning type of
analysis for biomedical systems
essentially helping us to uh identify
how certain biological functions are
affected uh when you're exposed to
certain chemicals but today uh we're
just going to focus on Supply Chain
management and uh data driven
optimization of these
systems now Supply Chain management
actually requires the coordination of
three distinct s time scales at the very
bottom is that you have your longer term
decisions which is your supply chain
structure and on top of that you have
your planning decisions that are Med
medium-term uh type of decisions and on
top of that you'll have uh short-term
scheduling decisions uh that uh happen
much much faster compared to the supply
chain and there's this natural hierarchy
as you can see for Supply Chain
management and when you're trying to
solve these problems the very intuitive
way to do it is approach it sequentially
so what you do is first you decide on
your longer term decisions for example
you decide where your facility locations
would go on the map you decide on your
supply chain structure
essentially and then you can determine
your production goals by looking at the
market demand and account for your
inventories decide how much to produce
once you decide that you take that
decision and take it to your scheduling
level where at the scheduling level
you're trying to allocate your sources
and you're actually trying to produce
what you have decided at the medium-term
decisions you're trying to assign your
tasks to the units you're trying to
schedule your entire production now the
sequential fashion is actually very
popular uh but it is also
uh a little bit uh problematic it is
less than ideal it's in the sense that
these different levels of the supply
chain uh decisions you have they're
actually interconnected because they are
shared variables across these different
layers so here's sort of like a quick
example of what happen so this is um a
case where we have uh two products we
want to produce these two products and
we have a demand profile and this demand
profile assume that we're we have it for
a week of of planning
period now what you do at the planning
level is that you look at these demand
profiles and decide I'm going to produce
this much every single day for these two
products now these are your planning
decisions but you take these decisions
without actually accounting your
scheduling level and then you go to the
scheduling level try to implement these
production targets and what happens is
you cannot actually reduce this much
because you essentially for example over
optimistically uh estimated your
production targets to be very high to
meet this demand and when you come to
the scheduling you will realize that
you're violating your capacity because
you cannot produce this much in a given
day so at the end of this you
essentially have an unsatisfied product
demand because you cannot uh produce
this much um at all but what you can do
rather than the sequential approach you
can formulate this as a hierarchical
approach and Bev programming essentially
captures that natural hierarchy uh very
very nicely so what you will do is you
put your production planning level and
I'm just going to focus on just the by
level optimization uh of it I'm not
going to talk about multi- level so
we're just looking at the integration of
the planning and scheduling levels here
so we have the planning level as our
higher level decisions it's going to
minimize our total cost of planning
subject to inventory balance
equations and the scheduling levels are
going to be embedded underneath this
planning level and you're going to
notice in this formulation that there
are shared variables across the planning
and scheduling levels now one thing that
is very very nice in the structure is
that you're not just accounting for the
objective function of the each
individual levels but this also ensures
that you do not run into violations in
your in your scheduling levels how is
that possible as you can see that this
optimization problem is essentially a
constraint on the upper level you can
see that's subject to minimization of
this so unless you have a globally
optimal scheduling level you do not have
a feasible solution for your ble problem
so this is a very neat and nice way of
doing it uh it ensures
feasibility but the problem is by level
programming problems are very very
difficult to solve even the most
simplistic case that you can think of
like a linear program constrained with
another linear program uh the resulting
problem is strongly MP hard and the
lower level problem uh is is essentially
yielding uh an overall problem that is
nonconvex and this is a demonstration of
how that happens so we have a linear
program constrainted with another linear
program and uh since the optim
optimality of this lower level is a
constraint on the upper level we can use
the Kish coner uh optimality conditions
to reduce this by level problem to a
single level optimization problem and
now we have our same objective function
but our constraints are now considering
the kkt conditions and you will notice
that the complementary slackness is
actually nonlinear so if you plot your
feasible region you end up with this
non-convex feasible region so right off
the bat right we had a linear program
considered with a linear program uh even
these simple cases require Global
optimization because retrieving uh the
solution of a non-convex uh problem is
not so
trival there's another problem that
comes from
scheduling uh formulations and that is
we have mixed integer formulations so we
cannot even use the kkt transformation
to start with I cannot simp reduce my B
Lev uh planning and scheduling
formulations with this trick and on top
of that you can have your uh production
demands uh to be stochastic so you don't
you may have a good idea but uh your
product demands could be very very
variable and you have to also account
for the multi follower nature of the
integrated formulation I'm going to come
into the detail on why the multi
follower nature exist in a bit more but
essentially when you're planning over
for multiple days you have to schedule
uh or you have to solve your scheduling
problem for every single day so it's not
just you're following one leader and one
follower you have one leader but multi
follower
structures now of course the difficulty
of this problem also was a was quite an
interest to the community and this is
just an indicative list of the previous
works and uh there are also U more
recent advances that are not listed here
here but I want you to focus on looking
at the solution strategy and different
flavors that we can explore for example
we can do branch and bound you can get
the Epsilon solution uh Epsilon optimal
solution with branch and bound but
unfortunately branch and bound uh
suffers with increasing number of
variables uh when it comes to Bev mixed
integer optimization you can do
parametric optimization you will get the
exact solution but you're limited to
certain types of problems with
parametric Theory
so you cannot actually solve nonlinear
non-convex problems you can use genetic
algorithms and genetic algorithms again
uh they're data driven techniques and
they're quite advantageous because you
can actually uh solve certain types of
by Lev mixed integer nonlinear programs
so they can address potentially these
very complicated structures but
unfortunately uh the feasibility nor
optimality is guaranteed because genetic
algorithms don't have a very robust way
of handling constraints you can use
penalty functions filtered approaches
and so on but you cannot absolutely
guarantee the feasibility of your
solution so what we have asked ourselves
is that can we use uh a data driven
approach and different than a genetic
algorithm to solve these BMI nlps that
contain a relatively High number of
variables with a feasibility guarantee
and what we have worked on is what we
call the Domino framework so we have
this biev optimization problem uh given
in this structure we have continuous
decision variables at the upper level
and we have mixed integer decisions at
the lower level and both levels can be
constrained um and what we do within the
structure or even a more simpler biev
programs what we do is we look at the
upper level
dimensionality and we create a design of
experiments on these upper level
decision variables you can use any type
of design of experiments you would like
um maybe you have uh some sort of
preference or maybe you have your own
design of experiments you can use that
but the idea is when you create these
design of experiments you look at each
of those samples and you fix them at the
lower level so for every X you fix them
at the lower level we deterministically
solve the lower level problem to Global
optimality and in this case as well you
can use any type of deterministic
Optimizer that you would like so if you
have like a linear milp you can use slex
if you have more nonlinear or minlp type
of problems you can use Baron antigon L
the global whichever you
prefer and then this allows us to once
you get that y star this allows us to go
back and evaluate our objective function
and constraint violations this usually
serves our as our input output data
because we have our X and now we have a
corresponding objective function value
and our constraint violations and then
we can pass this input output data to a
derivative free optimization sub routine
now this derivative free optimization
sub routine again you can use different
algorithms if you have preferences or
ease of implementation but the St free
optimization uh sub rtin is going to uh
continue uh adding new samples based on
its uh sample selection strategies it's
going to check whether it meets the
convergence criteria and once it meets
the con convergence criteria we will do
two checks one we're going to check
whether we satisfy all our graybox
constraints if not then we have to go
back and change our design so we didn't
have a feasible solution in this case
but if the answer is yes then we have to
do the final check remember that the
lower level uh Global optimality is a
Con on the upper level so if the lower
level is not solved to Global optimality
we do not find a feasible solution but
if it's globally optimal we do have a
guaranteed feasible solution for the B
program and as I said you can use many
different algorithms uh for the data
driven optimization step so I'm showing
you sort of the two ends of the spectrum
here one is Nomad Mash adaptive direct
search um this is essentially a pure
sample based strategy it makes these
Compass moves to get uh close to the uh
optimal solution so it's like gradient
descent without the actual gradients and
you evaluate your objective function uh
throughout this or you can have more
modelbased structures maybe you have
your own algorithm I brought Argonaut as
an example this is something that I have
also worked on and what Argonaut does is
that it builds individualized circuit
models for your objective functions and
your constraints so you essentially
create the surate optimization Problem
by collecting this data so for example
you can build these these constraint
regions and you can do bound tightening
around them uh you can use Global
optimization to solve uh the circuit
functions but you can either you know
based on your preferences you can either
choose a sample based strategy or a or a
model based strategy which can also be
local versus global it really depends on
your preferences so we actually
benchmark our framework uh with four
different solvers and we looked at the
comprehensive testest from the
literature that we can find and we
evaluated Domino over 100 Benchmark
problems and these problems um varied in
terms of flavors linear constraint with
linear uh continuous nonlinear cases
that could be you know going from LP QP
complexity to NLP NLP complexity we also
did mixed integer cases as much as we
could find um unfortunately we are
limited these are very very difficult
problems so it is hard to find uh these
Benchmark problems as well but again we
tried different complexities at the
mixed integer level as well and our
results have shown that we were actually
able to identify near Optimal Solutions
so these Benchmark problems with the
known Solutions we were either uh was
recovering that optimal solution or we
were very very close to it and all these
uh problem types also vary in
dimensionality number of constraints
number of lower and upper level
variables
to but I'm not going to go into the
detail of the benchmarking but I wanted
to go back and revisit the planning and
scheduling because this problem is a
little bit different than uh this uh the
The Benchmark problems that we had in
The Benchmark problems we had one leader
one follower like a typical B Lev
optimization problem but in the
integrated planning of scheduling as I
mentioned you have a multi follower
structure so you have your production
targets at the upper level and these are
decision variables for our data driven
optimizers to or to Domino to recover
but at the lower level if you're
planning for seven days you have to
solve your schedule for every single day
so you have to solve your schedule for
each planning period Then you have to
account for your inventories and those
inventories essentially go to your upper
level objective function calculation and
you'll recover a total cost and this
total cost becomes your output so you
have your input you have your output
data and you can use Domino to solve
this problem uh of course we have
constraints and I'm going to show you in
a in a little bit more detail on what
kind of constraints we have but for
example you can think of things like
inventories need to be positive um we
cannot have negative inventories in our
system so so that's one thing that we
ensure also meeting the
demand and I'm going to first
demonstrate some of the results on this
uh quite famous um scheduling problem so
this is a state task network of um of
the um scheduling problem with three
different feeds so we have feed ABC that
goes into uh four different units and
you're trying to schedule eight
different tasks and actually are trying
to produce two products and we said
let's start with uh seven planning days
and we created this demand profile so
this demand profile is completely uh
synthetic uh we wanted to start with
something that will start low Peak
midweek and then dial down so it's you
can see that it's almost like a normal
distribution in this case and then we
formulate our planning and scheduling
problem so what you have uh at the
condensed representation is this so we
have we look at our planning level our
total cost of planning is essentially
what we have for our inventory and our
production cost our inventory cost is
however however many inventory we carry
times their price and this inventory
carrying for every single planning
period actually depends on how much you
produce at at that day
uh plus anything that carried over from
the previous day minus the demand you
provide so you write this balance
equation to calculate your ending
inventory and we have constraints for
essentially enabling uh cyclic planning
uh we consider CYCC planning because
when you plan for the seven days and
you're trying to go to the next week
your um task doesn't end right you start
the next week so if you have for example
next week uh you have an inventory to
start with on the first day you need to
be able to produce that at the final
dayao so when you do just seven days
your your task doesn't end you have to
actually go to the next week and the
other week and the other week so we
enable that CYCC planning uh in our
calculations and this essentially is
actually a linear program on its own now
looking at the lower level problem now
you have the production cost at your uh
planning level OB objective but this
production cost actually comes from the
scheduling level and it is equal to the
fixed cost of production plus any
variable cost of material that you have
I'm not going to show you the entire set
of equations but this formulation has
allocation constraints storage
constraints duration sequence time
Horizon constraints and material
balances we're actually using the
continuous time formulation uh from
aetra to influ and their uh paper from
1998 so you can refer to that if you're
curious on the individual uh individual
equations but one thing that I would
like you to bring your attention is this
final bull point that is the production
Target satisfaction at the final event
point this is very important because
this is how that interconnection happens
between your planning level and the
scheduling level and here's how that
looks like so basically at the end of
the schedule and at the final uh time of
the scheduling you want your product s
that you produce exceed the production
Target you have at least be equal or
greater than or equal to the production
targets you have and remember that these
were the decision variables that we had
from our planning level and this is how
you do that inter
connection and your scheduling model in
this case is going to be an
MP now we use Domino to solve this
problem so we have an lpmp
formulation and you're seeing the
profiles for the first prod product over
seven planning days with two different
solvers the top solution is for nomad
the bottom solution is for argonut and
the red bars show here the demand orange
is the production and the gray one is
the starting day inventory so we would
like this production and the inventory
bars to essentially the their cumulative
um contribution should exceed the demand
and in all of these cases if you eyeball
it a little bit uh you will see that
satisfi the demand for all planing
periods and the very most important
thing is that the scheduling levels for
each of the planning uh days is actually
optimal so this is guaranteed optimal so
we can guarantee that you will be able
to realize this production you will see
that from The Nomad solution to argonut
there's a slight difference in the total
cost and this is basically because uh
some of the uh decision variables are at
a higher production level for argonut
compared to Nomad so The Nomad solution
is a bit more Tighter and that
essentially reflects on your higher
costs that you see and this is the
profile for product two same idea um we
see that both the production and the
inventory actually exceed the demand for
uh every single planning day so demand
satisfy for old planning periods and uh
our scheduling levels are optimal for
this case and this is a little bit more
clear you can see that argona chooses to
overproduce in day six and carry an
inventory whereas Nomad is a bit tighter
you uh produce exactly on the6 but over
produce seven so that when you go back
this is where the cyclic nature happens
when you go back to the first day next
week you actually have that inventory to
start with and you can still meet meet
this
demand now this was the lpmi lp
formulation but we know that Domino can
do so much more we know that we can
handle
nonlinear um formulations so what we
wanted to do is what if we actually
considered our variable cost to be
nonlinear so in reality the linear U
expression of the variable cost is just
an approximation variable costs are
nonlinear in nature so what we did was
that we uh took a quadratic variable
cost function in scheduling and we took
a cubic inventory cost function in the
planning level and we created this NLP
miqp formulation and we resolved the
same problem with the same uh demand
levels and what we have seen is that
again we can satisfy the demand for old
planning periods and our scheduling
levels are going to be optimal what
you're going to see is the the stri
difference in the total costs between
the NAD solution and the Argan solution
and this is primarily because of these
little slight differences in the
inventory um carryovers from day two and
day three so because you're now taking
the uh the cubic values of these your
cost difference is Amplified and if you
look at product two same case demand is
satisfied for all planning periods our
scheduling levels are optimal you can
see that for example day two difference
is a little bit more clear here and
these essentially translate into uh a
higher objective function value but
regardless of that whether you use uh a
sample based strategy or a model based
strategy within Domino framework you can
actually uh get guaranteed feasible
solutions for this problem now we can
also test the Domino consistency and
this is what we have done so the data
driven optimizers are uh sometimes could
be very uh dependent on where they start
especially the local strategies like
Nomad so what we do is we start with
different starting points so we did 10
random initializations with Nomad and we
resolved our problem uh and this is the
result for the NLP miqp you can see that
the error bars barely exist uh for
product one you do you do see some
variability here but it's not it's not
more than uh I believe 30 uh unit
material for these cases but throughout
the solution what we see is there's a
very low variability among the repeated
runs so we do actually have a very good
consistency in converging to the same
solution so uh the the confidence uh for
for getting the Domino solution is is
also very very
high now in these cases right uh our
product demands were deterministic even
though it was synthetic for us we gave
randomly some demand level um they were
still deterministic that we had one
demand we knew it through out the week
and we tested that now we wanted to gear
up and see what happens if our product
demand was uncertain essentially what if
we have um different kinds of scenarios
for the demand and how can we handle
them so we create these 10,000 scenarios
and we assume uh a normal distribution
around their
mean and uh what we do is we're going to
analyze in even a more simplified
motivating example so we start with one
feed and three tasks and one product and
we're still planning for 7 days so what
we do is we sort of Define these regions
within 20% standard deviation around the
mean and we say let's have low medium
and high demand and we're going to
create scenarios for our planning days
so we're going to start with uh the
first day demand known then we will go
to day two and three and we're going to
group them together and say that day two
and three can be subject to low medium
or high demand then for these
4567 we're going to group them as well
and say these can be again subject to
low medium and high demand the reason
why we did it this way you can obviously
do this grouping in many many different
ways we wanted to limit the number of
scenarios we cannot test the infinite
number of scenarios so we randomly
sampled nine
cases uh for these nine different
scenarios so we start with day one and
after day one you can have low medium or
high day two and three and if you have
low day two and three you can again have
low medium and high day four to day
seven and the same idea repeats for
medium and high levels for day two and
three now I'll show you how these
scenarios look like so for this case uh
you're seeing the planning days and the
demand levels we start from the same
first day demand and you can see that
how variable and how we capture these
very different scenarios uh throughout
our study and one thing that I would
like you to notice even though when we
Mark or group our days say that I want
low or medium demand levels for these
two and three they're not necessarily
the same demand we just sample from the
same region randomly so they could be
variable as you can see in the blue one
uh day two is is high higher than day
three or the purple one you see day two
is lower than day three and so on so
we're trying to cover uh a sort of a
good spread of theand levels that we can
see for our production and of course we
would also need to uh change our
deterministic formulation so this was
our condensed representation that we
solved at once now you have to solve it
per scenario because now you have to
calculate your total cost of planning
for for every single scenario that you
have and in more detail right we have to
consider the occurrence of scenario
probability so we're trying to calculate
a total stochastic cost of planning in
this case we're taking them equal but if
you have real insight to the production
uh you can say that certain you know
occurrences are higher in probability or
lower in probability but in our case
it's essentially 1 over n then you look
at the total cost of planning similar
objective function now we just have to
solve for per scenario then we have the
same equations for the inventory cost
again they have to happen for now every
planning period And every
scenario and you look at the scheduling
model we still have the continuous time
formulation we still have the same uh
biev uh interconnection between our
planning and scheduling so we are still
interested in producing more than at
least more than the production uh
targets we have greater than equal to
the production targets we have but we
need to make sure that we satisfy this
not just for one scenario but for the
entire set of scenarios and for the
entire planning period so this also uh
necessitates for us to update how we
execute Domino our inputs are still
production
targets uh we are trying to solve our
SCH
throughout the entire planning Horizon
but now we have to do it for every
single scenario you can execute them in
parallels to to save uh some
competitional expense you need to
account for your inventories per
scenario calculate your plan and cost
per scenario then bring them together as
a total stochastic cost of planning with
uh your probability of urance for each
of these scenarios and this total
stochastic planning cost essentially
serves as your output and now when you
do that um this is uh for a motivating
example you see the data driven
complexity we have six decision
variables and uh we have uh quite a bit
of graybox constraints with a couple of
few hundred uh constraints at the lower
level uh you will see that our solution
is actually geared to our worst case
scenario when we had high demand for
days two and three four five six and
seven throughout the week we just have
high demand and since we're trying to
figure out one production Target and we
don't know which scenario we will face
uh this makes sense that we at least
satisfy the worst case scenario and on
top of that if you don't face that what
happens is you're going to accumulate
more inventory and that's natural
because you're you're sort of uh geing
your production targets uh for seeing a
very uh very high demand
but for all uh these scenarios and for
the entire planning period across all
these scenarios we satisfy the product
demands and our scheduling levels are
optimal so that's a that's uh actually a
very promising result for us because
you're solving now nine times uh this
very very difficult optimization problem
to get one a feasible
solution now again we assess the effect
of initial
uh on the performance you will see a
little bit more variability compared to
the deterministic case but are still our
standard error for our objective
function value is actually very very
small um so we do see some variability
here and there but they do not exceed 27
units of material so the overall
consistency uh for Domino is essentially
acceptable and even for these 10 random
initializations even when we see uh
variabilities we actually don't have an
in feasible solution all these runs uh
were completely uh feasible with
scheduling levels uh that are solved to
Global
optimality now if we shift gears for a
multiproduct now let's say you're trying
to produce four more product in a more
complicated uh scheduling structure but
still using the same idea of grouping
and identifying low medium and high
demand what you will do is we will
create
individual uh scenarios for all these
different products again we're trying to
um create a nice spread here to cover uh
all the possible um uh possibilities
that we may potentially see in our
production or our planning level and we
run Domino for all these cases now our
decision variable complexity is
quadrupled uh we have um couple of
hundred gray box constraints that we
need to handle at the uh at the data
driven level and we have you know close
to a thousand constraints at the
scheduling level complexity and this is
a big big scheduling model to handle but
because we're using that deterministic
optimization level it actually helps us
a lot to be able to address these
problems and like in the case that we
have seen for the one product so I'm
just showing you the first product
results here we're actually a very
consistent L uh find feasible Solutions
across all the planning periods the
demand is satisfied scheduling levels
are optimal and um there's definitely
room for improvement for example there's
this like very high carrying over of
inventories even even at the worst case
scenario so that means that you have to
actually produce a lot over the last day
but uh we know that this could this
could be realizable through the
structure and we can show all these you
know all these uh similar profiles for
product two three and four but for the
sake of time uh I'm just showing product
one now one other thing that we have
done uh and this is more tied into the
performance of data driven Optimizer is
that what um how how does the lower
level complexity essentially relate to
the performance of our data driven
optimization so if you have sample-based
strategies like nomat uh your your
sampling time becomes very very
important because that's your only way
of getting information and what you're
seeing here for the motivating example
and for the multiproduct case study as
well these green bars are showing you
the objective function value the total
stochastic uh cost of planning so in the
multi product case you will see that
there's a drop with on the x-axis you
seeing the number of event points in the
scheduling
formulation uh so the effect of number
of event points in the scheduling
formulation is essentially increasing
the number of constraints number of
variables that you consider so you're
increasing the complexity of your of
your lower level Problem by increasing
the number of event points and you can
see that for the multiproduct case you
can actually go up Beyond thousand
constraints at the lower level now what
we see is that uh initially uh we see a
drop in the computational expense
of executing the scheduling levels but
as you make it more and more complex
your um computational time increases a
lot and if you normalize it to the total
number of samples that you collect for
example for a motivating example when
your event points was was six and you're
within some moderate number of um
variables and constraints it actually
costs about 25 seconds to collect one
sample but with uh higher complexity
scheduling levels this almost it
actually doubles uh and goes beyond this
the same for the multiproduct case study
it goes up to 121 seconds per sample so
the sampling um time actually becomes
very very important and we do paralyze
it and we we are trying to benefit from
the parallel Computing
capabilities but uh 100 plus seconds per
one sample becomes very very exhaustive
uh especially for algorithms like
Nomad but we wanted to go beyond so this
didn't really stop us we wanted to go
and
solve um scheduling problems with minlp
levels and minlp levels that we
artificially did not induce so in the
first case we made our variable costs
nonlinear to to um make it a little bit
more difficult so we did have to change
the uh problem type to be able to
achieve that and uh this is an example
from crude oil operations very similar
idea so our vessels are going to carry
oil and uh you want to schedule um sort
of the these vessels uh transferring
their oil to storage tanks and these
storage tanks will then um feed the oil
to the charging tanks and a blending
occurs the blending occurs because oil
compositions vary widely from Bas on
where they're collected so you're trying
to mix two oils with two different
compositions and there's a demand that
goes uh from these charging tanks to the
cord oil distillation unit now because
this blending exists and because the
compositions are are different you need
to add component balance to your
continuous time formulation and that
component balance is essentially
nonlinear so your scheduling model even
though the rest of them are are um
integer linear or mixed integer your
linear Expressions your component
balance introduces that
nonlinearity uh but you still have the
demand from charging tanks essentially
imposing by by Lev feasibility so our
overall scheduling model here is
minlp I'm not going to go into the
details of the
formulation but we create the this uh
longer planning period uh for for
satisfying the demand and oil mixes and
we we do have two oil mixes in this case
the only thing with paid attention when
creating this demand is to not to have
um high demand throughout the 15 days so
we won't be obviously able to satisfy
that so we wanted something that goes up
and down but you see the complexity uh
of the problem here the data driven
complexity is about 28 variables we have
62 uh constraints and we have couple of
hundred uh constraints at the lower
level as well and since this is minlp
now we're solving it with Baron
and here are the results um again we can
actually satisfy the demand uh for these
crude oil mixes and each of the
scheduling levels over the 15 days uh
are optimal um we uh satisfi the product
demand for the entire planning period
one interesting observation we had with
the minlp type of problems is that uh
Nomad was able to find uh very
consistent uh solutions to it but but
even though Argonaut was a global
approach uh but being a model uh based
data driven Optimizer it wasn't able to
find a guaranteed feasible solution
within 24 hours of running so normally
it was really really fast in the
previous cases and we were able to get
some close values for The Nomad in this
um more complicated problem we seen that
uh Nomad as a sample based strategy
actually did much much better and you
can increase the complexity even more uh
you can have three charging tanks that
increases your data driven um decision
uh variable complexity and the number of
graybox constraints that you're trying
to handle you will also increase your
lower level complexity now you're trying
to solve thousands of constraints in an
minlp scheduling problem so that's a
very difficult problem to solve with um
in this case we limited ourselves to to
um seven ping days but again create
these random demand profiles solve it
with dominal and you will see that again
we can satisfy um the the product demand
across the entire planning period with
each of these schedules uh that are
being optimal now we did for this case
we did see one INF feasible run recorder
by Nomad uh now as the complexity is
substantially um has substantially
increased compared to the lpmp type of
uh scale scheduling formulations um this
is somewhat somewhat expected and argon
couldn't even find a solution uh for
this case uh within 24 hours and with
that I would just like to um share some
concluding remarks we have developed and
extendedly uh tested our Domino
framework which is a bevel multi
follower mixed integer nonlinear uh
programming um uh solver and what our
unique feature with
is that we're still approximating these
y level optimization problems with uh to
a single level optimization problem but
we do this in a data driven way we
collect samples at the upper level and
we fix them at the lower level and solve
the lower level problem to Global
optimality and we tested this framework
on a bunch of case studies from
Benchmark problems to uh different type
of scheduling problems integrated
planning and scheduling problems to a
very complicated Min NLP Cru oil
operations case study and we were able
to provide guaranteed feasible solutions
for all um one thing that I would like
to note is that we are trying to speed
up the algorithm so the sample
collection uh becomes very very
important for sample based optimizers
like Nomad it affects the consistency
and we would also like to revisit the
stochastic formulation for the more
complex uh scheduling problems we had
and with that I would like like to
acknowledge uh my graduate students
Hassan especially LED uh this work and
our funding sources from different uh
different places and I will also like to
acknowledge our collaborators uh
Professor Selana aido from University of
University of Wisconsin Madison and
Professor vasilis haritos from
University College London and finally I
would also like to acknowledge uh the
department of chemical and biomolecular
Engineering at Yukon they have been an
amazing support um so um it's really uh
it's really uh was a pleasure to do this
work here so with that thank you so much
and I can take any questions you might
have thank you thank you so much for the
wonderful talk nice nice very nice um so
let's have a Q&A sessions um if you have
any questions please uh unmute yourself
and ask questions
while you are thinking of your questions
maybe I can ask my questions um uh so
this is data driven and you relying on
the sampling and how many data um you
know do you have to
generate
so yeah so it really depends on the
scale of the problem some of them um are
I would say a couple of thousand but it
is adaptive right the optimizers are
trying to build confidence um in in
their
Solutions uh but for um more complex
problems it could go up to you know
10,000 samples if you can afford it
obviously so that's why I say um
sampling is a bit important and that's
why we're trying to work on uh speeding
up the algorithm what samp sampling
algorithm have you used so far so so
Nomad essentially works as its own
because it's sorry about that um so it's
evaluating these samples on its own for
Argonaut yeah so we for Argonaut we had
ltin hypercube design and the way that
that algorithm works is also adaptive so
you're building these surrogates you
optimize them those Optimal Solutions
become new sampling points and you keep
iterating and uh the argonut one because
it's model based it's more sample
efficient so um you can get away with
you know couple of hundred or couple of
thousand in the worst case but because
Nomad is more sample uh
driven it it does collect a lot of a lot
of
samples I see well you have shown this
you know application of this algorithm
to supply chain which is Road app
applicability especially in industry I'm
I'm sure laen here Lawrence liore we are
very interested in those supply chain as
well because I mean everything is about
the process engineering right um are
you uh actually work with any industry
partner and showing this algorithm and
and apply this in real life
problems uh so not yet uh it would be
awesome yeah not yet it would be awesome
to um to really uh team up with industry
the the initial sort of um idea actually
came from food energy water Nexus so
that's also a very interconnected
problem that you can formulate with uh a
bevel optimization problem and then we
wanted to go to more complex supply
chain uh supply chain analysis so I
think that's naturally how evolved uh
was was from a different different
problem type to start with but it would
be super interesting I know that the
industry scheduling problems are far
more complicated um and and far more
difficult to
solve yeah for example like um Amazon
would be very interesting yeah yeah and
also another application like flight
scheduling like the exactly exact they
will be very interested in in this work
um
yeah I'm I'm sure there are I'm I'm not
personally working on the the supply
chain uh problem but I'm sure there are
many people who work on the problems
related to the supply chain in lence Lio
as well so feel free to uh reach out to
Oru um and do the collaborations that
would be awesome um well since I'm not
working on the supply chain I'm more
like the physical simulation guy um and
in the optimization setting you know as
you know like those sampling individual
sampling takes a lot of times you have
to solve on full simulation and
sometimes just one full simulation takes
one week even using the HPC machines we
have here yeah um so yeah I mean
that any idea
yeah extending this to con
optimization yeah so um I think I had to
ask this question yeah I know um so um
when we when we initially work with
Argonaut not in a b Lev setting but we
worked with a very expensive um
Reservoir simulation so one sample was
like 300 seconds and that's even a lot
um so one thing uh that that you can do
is you can pick your so first of all
model based data driven optimization is
going to be much much better because
they're going to be more sample
efficient because you you now have the
circuit that will uh help you and you
can use more interpolating functions
like uh cing or radial basis functions
that are more sample efficient so you
can build
relationships uh with with a couple of
100 uh points but uh now you know seeing
a little bit more uh development on the
symbolic regression side um you can also
uh use more like pins or uh or
symbolically regress type of Expressions
to alleviate some complexity essentially
you can Ser create the surrogate of your
simulation that that you have you're
going to have high confidence about
and use that do this over that surrogate
but obviously you want some
extrapolation capabilities and whatnot
um that's why I I sort of recommend
doing these these more physics informed
or hybrid uh type of machine learning
models uh but I think uh that is
possible uh to to circumvent that that
issue yeah well that was a good answer
um I mean even physics in Network or
symbolic R there there are so much
research needs to be done but yeah
that's definitely one good directions to
pursue um well is there any questions I
think I gave you guys plenty of time to
think about
question um if not well let's thank our
speaker foru for the wonderful talk and
um really really hope that there will be
you know future collaboration between
you and Lawrence limore if not Lawrence
liore with other
industry people and this is very useful
stuff thank you so much it was a
pleasure